Hi there.
So this is going to be an interesting,
fairly short course.
We've primarily built it to help
you learn more about Backbone.js.
Backbone.js is a library that helps
you organize your web applications.
If you're completely new to organizing
web applications consider going through
JavaScript design patterns first.
I've put a link to that course
in the instructor notes.
Now i'm going to be honest with you,
learning about backbone
is an important objective for this
course but it's not my only objective.
The other objective I have is for
you to refine your ability
to learn new things by exploring
resources on the internet.
This is a critical trait to have for
any professional web developer.
So here's how the course
is going to work.
We've created a list of
resources from the internet.
Things you might find in a Google search
to help you get more familiar with
Backbone.
Spend the time to really
go through each resource.
Now, trust me on this, these
resources will help you get better.
I've read them all myself and
they're all pretty good.
Also, don't rush.
You'll be spending between 30 and
90 minutes on each one.
For each resource,
we also will give you the opportunity
to engage with your peers.
Ask an answer each other's questions.
Teaching is another incredible way
to solidify your own knowledge, so
help each other out.
Once you're done with these resources
you'll be in a great place to tackle
your next project.
Now let's dive into those resources.